how's it going everyone it's Warren
welcome back got a little bit of a
different video today because we were
supposed to get the venom 2 trailer
today but most of the day has passed and
it's not here yet
so yesterday a ton of people posted
screenshots of what appeared to be Andy
Serkis from his official Instagram page
posting that the venom 2 trailer was
supposed to come tomorrow which is today
but Sony usually releases their trailers
pretty early on in the morning so if it
was going to happen today it would have
already happened now to this hour many
people are claiming that they saw
notification that Andy Serkis posted
they clicked on it they saw the photo
and then he deleted it but at the same
time a lot of people are saying that it
was fake no one ever saw it and it was
photoshopped by somebody I'm not really
sure what happened I don't know if it
got pushed back I don't know if it was
fake and it was never going to happen
but I just wanted to apologize for
everybody because I truly believe that
it was going to come out and I did a
video on it yesterday stating that I was
going to come out as well so looks like
whoever photoshopped this or created
this or maybe it's real and just got
pushed back but it looks like they got
us all so maybe it'll come out soon
within the week or maybe not at this
point it's kind of hard to tell what's
real people are photoshopping fake
pictures etc but again the trailer
didn't come out today we all thought it
was going to so just wanted to say sorry
I'm hearing that Sony actually does
announce their trailers a day or so in
advance so when the trailer finally does
come we should know about it from Sony
which of course would be official but
again sorry somebody photoshopped and
faked this photo or if it got pushed
back I'm sorry as well we were all
pretty excited about it but hopefully it
comes soon and of course when it does
I'll be doing a breakdown on it as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof